اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اهلا بكم مدير
مستشفى الشفاء يقول للجزيره انهم يتعرضون
للاباده ورئيس قسم الحروق بمجمع الشفاء
يؤكد للجزيره وفات اغلب الجرحى والمرضى في
قسم العنايه المركزه بسبب انقطاع الاكسجين
والوقود ويشير الى وضع صعب يعيشه الاطفال
الخدج الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه يقوم
بتفتيش ابنيه المستشفى ويؤكد ان العمليه
معقده وان البحث مستمر وحماس تنفي الروايه
الاسرائيليه وتصفها
بالفضيحه شهداء وجرحى جراء قصف على منازل
في خانيونس ومخيم النصيرات ومدرسه في حي
الزيتون هذا وقالت كتائب القسام انها
اجهزت على قوه اسرائيليه وفخ اخت انفاقا
في بيت حنون ودمرت 21 اليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن ارتفاع عدد قتلاه الى
52 بعد مقتل نائب قائد
سري مع اعلان الجهاز المركزي للاحصاء
الفلسطيني ان اكثر من 800000 انسان ما
زالوا في محافظتي غزه وشمال القطاع الصليب
الاحمر يقول ان فريقه غير قادر على تقديم
الخدمات المطلوبه والصحه العالميه تعرب عن
قلقها من تردي الاوضاع الصحيه وبرنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يقول ان قطاع يتلقى 10%
من احتياجاته اليوميه من الغذاء بلينكن
يؤكد التمسك بحكم فلسطيني لغزه مع فتره
انتقاليه لحفظ الامن ونتنياهو يقول ان
اسرائيل تريد الابقاء على مسؤوليه عسكريه
لها في غزه في حين ترفض هيئات امميه
مناقشه اي مقترحات احاديه لاقامه مناطق
عازله وهنيه يقول ان حماس متجذرا في
القطاع وان الفلسطينيين هم من يحددوا
مستقبله الى
اللقاء